good morning heck it's tuesday the
anthropocene reviewed book comes out two
weeks from tomorrow and i am a vast
collection of exposed nerve endings
today's video comes to you in three
parts part one what the most and least
viewed vlogbrothers videos say about
youtube
and about us so alexander daily recently
published an analysis of vlogbrothers
views by
year as well as our most and least
viewed video of every year since 2007.
a few things stand out here first there
was this huge surge of views in 2013 and
especially in 2014 as the success of the
fault in our stars meant that
nerdfighteria drifted closer to like
broader pop culture that was weird and
this also affected the views from 2007
to 2012 because lots of people went back
and watched those videos and you can
also sort of see the moment when in late
after an algorithm update our videos
stopped appearing on the trending page
at the time i was really worried this
would like destroy the community because
it meant fewer new people discovering
our videos but
in fact at least from my perspective the
opposite happened
i think the community actually became
much stronger partly because being off
the trending page made the comment
section
vastly more pleasant and partly because
all these nerdfighter groups emerged
around that same time like tuataria
and other discord communities and that
brings us to the real weirdness on
display here i am heavily conditioned to
think of more views as being good and
fewer views as being bad but
here our least viewed videos tend to be
much
more important than our most viewed
videos now that wasn't always the case
like in 2007 our most viewed video osseo
deathly hallows was probably also our
most important of that year because it
brought thousands of new people into
nerdfighteria many of whom had
experience building online communities
and developing productive fandoms like
we didn't really invent nerdfighteria
they did and without osseo deathly
hallows i don't think vlogbrothers would
still be a thing but then once the
community got going it changed like look
at our most and least viewed videos of
2010 our most viewed video was top 10
animal power moves which like
nothing against it as a work of art but
i i don't think it changed the world
much
our least viewed video that year was an
introduction to a conference we were
starting called vidcon which would go on
to become quite important to us as
individuals and also to the culture and
business of online video
since 2010 nine of our 11 least viewed
videos have been about the project for
awesome which in that time frame has
raised over 12 million dollars for
charity so i would argue that most years
our single most
unpopular video is also our single most
important video
of course it's almost impossible to
quantify impact that's why we settle for
lesser measures like star ratings and
views and watch time and so on but after
looking at 15 years of analytics my main
conclusion is that we shouldn't worry
much about views but we should be
extremely worried all the time about the
health and productivity of the community
and it turns out that more views if they
lead to toxic comment sections are bad
for community and shared projects even
if they aren't that broadly popular
are good for it that's why unless we
want a particular video to reach a broad
audience we don't upload custom
thumbnails or try to optimize metadata
or whatever we do that on other channels
crash course for instance where the
priority is trying to reach the most
learners but here
the priority is something else something
that's harder to quantify and i don't
know about you but i really love the vog
brothers community right now and that's
the metric that matters the most to me
part two book tour i am going on a
virtual tour to celebrate the release of
the anthropocene reviewed book and to
support local independent bookstores
around the country there's a special
guest each night it'll be really fun we
will discuss the anthropocene and the
five star scale and
much else and also each night together
we will create a new review
using a writing strategy i developed for
the book links in the doobly-doo to find
out more and get tickets part three
speaking of vlogbrothers history a
lovely tradition we have been observing
around here since 2008 is that whenever
either of us has a book come out
the author reads the first chapter in a
usually over four minutes vlogbrothers
video
and that tradition will be continuing
soon with an animated video of the
opening of the anthropocene reviewed
okay
because it says on my 2021 vision board
dftba thanks for making osseo deathly
howls all those years ago i will see you
on friday